en el vídeo pasado teníamos una placa
infinita con densidad de carga uniforme
y además tomamos una carga q h unidades
arriba n sobre la placa ba lo que
estábamos haciendo era calcular el campo
eléctrico o bueno la componente n del
campo eléctrico de un anillo de radio r
alrededor de la base de donde se
proyectaba la carga y bueno determinamos
que era esta expresión de acá con esto
podemos decir que eso justo es el campo
eléctrico no sólo la componente en ye
sino el campo eléctrico porque por el
argumento que teníamos acá arriba las
componentes en x se van a cancelar así
que calcular la componente en ya basta
para calcular el campo eléctrico bueno
lo que habíamos dicho es que ahora
teníamos que sumar todas estas
expresiones para todos los radios para
determinar el campo eléctrico causado
por toda la placa por toda la placa
entonces eso es lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita sumando todas estas componentes
en jr vamos a obtener la componente n
del campo eléctrico del campo eléctrico
de todas
y con eso pues vamos a determinar el
campo eléctrico no sólo la componente en
ye por el argumento de simetría vale
entonces vamos a hacer justo eso y ahora
sumar bueno sumar no es precisamente
sumar sino que es integrar porque
estamos sumando una infinidad de radios
y además tenemos aquí un cierto de r
entonces justo lo que tenemos que hacer
ahorita es una integral vale entonces
esto va a ser un poco de matemáticas
pesadas por eso baje para abrirme un
poco de espacio y además deje el dibujo
para que no se nos olvide que estamos
haciendo a veces es fácil perderse en
las cuentas pero bueno vamos a hacerlo
entonces déjame déjame ponerle y ahora
si este es el mero mero
el campo eléctrico que nos interesa es
igual a la integral de y lo que vamos a
lo que vamos a hacer es sumar todas
estas expresiones k por h por 2 y sigma
r
/ / h cuadrada + r cuadrada a la tres
medios de r y las queremos bueno las
queremos considerar todas estas
expresiones para todos los radios de
modo que cubran todo el plano entonces
vamos a pensar desde que el radio es
cero hasta que el radio es infinito
entonces esto de aquí ya nos da la
expresión para el campo eléctrico que
nos interesa muy bien esta integral
parece más o menos fea así que déjame
sacar las constantes las que no dependen
de r para que se vea un poco más
atacable entonces voy a sacar todo
excepto este 2 que ahorita nos va a
quedar este pues cómodo que esté ahí
adentro entonces sacando todo lo demás
que sería un
y cig maca h lo voy a poner así bueno en
el orden que están allá cada h
sigma por la integral de 0 a infinito de
12 r
/ h cuadrada más r cuadrada de r de r
muy bien entonces queremos determinar
esta integral ya no se ve tan fea es con
respecto a r ahora para resolverla es
básicamente hacer la regla de la cadena
inversa o sea hacer una sustitución
entonces déjame hacer esta sustitución
para ver cuánto nos queda la sustitución
que nos conviene a perdonar y me faltan
tres medios la sustitución que nos
conviene exponer y igual a este
denominador bueno a este cachito del
denominador h cuadrada masri cuadrada
vamos a ver qué nos queda voy a hacer la
sustitución de este lado voy a poner y
bueno lo que queremos es determinar la
integral ahorita voy a hacer la
indefinida de dos r / h cuadrada más r
cuadrada a la tres medios de r y lo que
propongo es hacer la sustitución o igual
a h cuadrada
más ere cuadrada
de este modo si hacemos y si derivamos
con respecto a r dvd r es igual a pues
la h es constante con respecto a r así
que nada más nos queda 12 r y por lo
tanto tenemos que de un dv es igual a 12
r de r de esta forma esta integral
indefinida es igual a la integral de déu
de 1 entre igual a tres medios igual a
tres medios por lo que es lo mismo la
integral de iu a la menos tres medios de
eeuu y esta es fácil de hacer verdad
esta es simplemente pues algo elevado a
una potencia entonces tenemos que
sumarle uno a la menos un medio y
dividir entre el exponente o sea nos
quedaría menos 2 si entonces sería eso
de ahí aquí bueno o sea sería bueno
ponerle el mace pero después cuando
hagamos la integral definida pues ya no
nos va a importar esa constante porque
se van a cancelar ok entonces esto está
en términos de eeuu ya nada más
no voy a poner aquí ya nada más lo
ponemos en términos de de errebal
entonces es menos 2 dividido entre
porque elevar a la menos es dividir
entre la raíz cuadrada de h cuadrada más
ere cuadrada muy bien entonces lo único
que hice de este lado aquí a la derecha
es encontrar la integral indefinida de
esta expresión pero ahora me interesa
pues hacerla definida entonces déjame
regresar al lado derecho voy a tomar
este color azul que está bonito entonces
me queda igual a k h
sigma
vale
kh y sigma y tenemos que poner la
integral definida y la integral definida
de esta expresión pero ya calculamos la
indefinida entonces ya nada más basta
con evaluar con evaluar menos 2 entre
raíz cuadrada de h cuadrada más ere
cuadrada
en infinito y a eso restarle la
evaluación en cero si simplemente el
segundo teorema fundamental del cálculo
muy bien entonces cuánto nos queda pues
vamos a ver o sea que le sucede a esta
expresión se evalúa en infinito si
evalúa en infinito entonces aquí abajo
me queda aún algo al infinito r al 4 sea
infinito al cuadrado es infinito esto de
aquí me queda muy grande entonces esto
es 0 esta expresión es cero
entonces nos quedaría acá h y sigma por
0 - y luego esta expresión evaluada en 0
entonces esta expresión evaluada en 0
aquí arriba nos queda menos 2 y aquí
abajo si r si r 0 nos queda raíz de h
cuadrada entonces este menos con este
menos se hace más dos entre raíz
cuadrada de h cuadrada vamos a
simplificar un poco para ver que nos
quedan
esto de aquí es igual
h sigma y aquí el 22 sep y sigma y
tenemos que dividir dividir entre la
raíz de h cuadrada pero la raíz de h
cuadrado simplemente h
entonces observa aquí tenemos h aquí
tenemos h se cancelan y de este modo
hasta el final nos queda dos por k por
pi
por sigma y déjame poner esto en un
color así más padre en un color más
brillante porque esta de acá ya es la
mera mera expresión para el campo
eléctrico de la placa infinita sobre
esta carga que pusimos por acá ahora
esto está padrísimo sí fíjate teníamos
una placa infinita con carga uniforme y
pusimos un cierto punto altura h
entonces pues parecería ser que pues la
h tendría que interactuar aquí pero no
esta expresión de acá es independiente
de h no importa a qué altura pongamos la
carga obtenemos el mismo campo eléctrico
entonces justo eso lo que nos está
diciendo es que el campo eléctrico es
constante y por lo tanto la fuerza es
constante verdad una vez que ponemos una
carga la fuerza que se ejerce es
constante
entonces el campo es igualito por todas
partes y por lo tanto es un campo
eléctrico constante que está padrísimo
además por aquí hay otras constantes
verdad que podemos pues analizar las
miradas o sea finalmente de qué depende
el campo eléctrico pues
2 que es un numerito de acá la constante
de q lo que es otro numerito de pi está
padre que tenga un día tendríamos que
pensar en eso a ver qué quiere decir
pero bueno en el fondo la única cosa
eléctrica que estamos pidiendo es este
sigma que es la densidad vale entonces
el campo eléctrico depende básicamente
nada más de la densidad bueno espero que
esto te haya parecido súper
satisfactorio fue un problema largo y
maratónico pero llegamos a un resultado
bien bonito que el campo eléctrico no
depende de la altura entonces si pongo
una carga ahí o si pongo la carga ahí
entonces a esta altura esta altura oa
esta altura en cualquiera de esas
situaciones tenemos que la fuerza
ejercida o bien el campo eléctrico son
constantes vale bueno a partir de esta
información que hicimos en estos en esto
en este vídeo y en el anterior ahora sí
vamos a poder pensar que existen los
campos eléctricos uniformes y con esto
pues ya vamos a platicar un poco más
cómodamente acerca de las placas
paralelas y de qué sucede lejos de las
orillas
bueno nos vemos pronto